Administration
[Applause]
[Music]
testing one million two million three
well you can always hear that anyway
uh you know when I came down today it's
been it's been 50 uh 54 years
since I drove down uh what was in the
highway six The Cornhusker Highway to
come to Lincoln to school
and even then there was a lot of
nostalgia attached with it because my
father had uh attended the University of
Nebraska in the 1920s
he was editor of the daily Nebraskan and
one day a young woman from West Point a
student came in to apply for a job as a
reporter on The Daily Nebraska and uh
and my father not only hired her as a
reporter but he married her shortly
thereafter so both my parents attended
here my grandfather
on my mother's side was here in the in
the 1890s and uh uh so a lot of good
things have happened to me because of
the University of Nebraska I received a
terrific education here I was telling
the dean
um the most valuable thing
I learned here but I learned a lot but
the most valuable was was uh accounting
and we had a wonderful Professor named
Ray Dean uh there may even be something
named for him down here isn't there yeah
I mean he was I'd been to the Wharton
School I went to Columbia Graduate
School uh subsequently but I took a lot
of accounting courses but by far the
best instruction I received in
accounting came from raiding and and
there's nothing more important people
ask me what they should take in business
school and and uh or even if they don't
go to business school what they need to
know before getting in business and I
tell them you know you have to you have
to understand accounting it's the
language of it it would be it's like
being in a foreign country without
knowing the language if you're in
business and you don't understand
accounting so it it it you want to get
as comfortable with that as you are with
the English language it it's made me uh
a lot of money because I I listen to
what Ray Dean had to say 53 or four
years ago and have been able to
understand uh
what I was seeing on pieces of paper
what that told me about businesses and
the limitations of what it told me about
businesses I mean but that's the way we
invest uh yesterday I was in Knoxville
Tennessee
and we bought a company we agreed to buy
a company called Clayton Homes about a
week ago it's a big
company in a manufactured home business
so we agreed to pay 1.7 billion dollars
for it
I made that deal over the phone without
ever meeting the people there but I had
seen enough
through Reading 10ks 10 cues annual
reports but looking at figures
what they tell me in terms of the kind
of people even running the place the
kind of accounting decisions they make
and so on I was able to make that 1.7
billion dollar transactions over the
phone yesterday was the first time I met
the people
and their board of directors had
actually approved the deal a week
earlier so it's uh you know I couldn't
have done that if I hadn't have uh you
know I had a great time at radines class
53 years ago so if I'm if I'm going to
tell one thing aside from this
particular leadership class of course uh
if I'm going to tell one thing uh I I
would I would I would tell you that uh
get comfortable with it you know it it
may not happen the first week or the
first month in the class but but get
very comfortable with accounting so that
I run into CEOs periodically
uh who really don't understand it you
know they try to Bluff their way through
and uh you can just say you can see in
their faces they're frightened almost
one day somebody hands them a balance
sheet or an income statement they really
don't know what it means and they have
to count on somebody else and that's
something you shouldn't count on we make
all our acquisition decisions ourselves
I mean we don't call in Consultants or
anybody we don't call it an investment
bankers much to their disgust uh no
Investment Banking fees into Clayton
Homes deal uh because you know it's my
responsibility Ryan Berkshire to
understand enough about our acquisition
decisions uh to make them uh based on
the numbers that I see and and what I
see there this course however is about
leadership and I like to talk just for a
minute about that
and then I'd like to really talk about
whatever's on your mind and I'll uh
we'll get questions but you know
leadership obviously is it's a very it's
a very simple thing in concept
uh my job as the leader of Berkshire
Hathaway
is to have visions and and goals
for the company overall with a long time
Horizon attached to them
and then to get those goals accomplished
through other people that's what that's
what it's all about I can't do it myself
so I have to I have to I have to know
where I want us to get to I have to see
over the next Mountain there possible
but then I have to get a lot of other
people to look over that mountain with
me and really do the job I mean they are
the ones that get accomplished so it's
getting things done through other people
now Berkshire is like some
like many large corporations in certain
ways but it's really quite different in
many ways uh
we have over 150 000 people now working
for Berkshire Hathaway in dozens of
companies uh throughout this country
primarily and even abroad a little bit
we have exactly 15.8 people in
headquarters
and Deborah came down with me today so
we've only got 13.8 uh there today and
we're probably working just as well with
those 13.8 as we would if Deb and I were
in the office but uh that is a that's an
unusual organization I mean we we have
dozens of operating managers CEOs of
their businesses out there running them
today and they do it without any
direction from the home office except
for one very limited piece of direction
that I give them which I'll get to in a
second but we have these people and
they're an unusual group of people
running these businesses because most of
them have sold their businesses to us
and they're very very wealthy
three-quarters of our managers do not
need to work financially you have no
reason financially to work probably
three quarters of them are worth at
least
50 million dollars and and and we have
some that are worth in the billions and
yet these people jump out of bed every
morning
you know and and work and they work
weekends and they love working and why
is that and what's the key to that
well the key really
is the same reason I keep working you
know I'm 72 I'm getting Social Security
now so again I
should be in Florida you know pushing
shuffleboard around or something of A
Sort but but
I do what I can do anything in the world
I want to do but what I want to do is
run Berkshire Hathaway now why do I want
to run at that point there's a couple
things yeah a I get to paint my own
painting
you know I go down there every day and I
feel like you know I feel like
Michelangelo they're you know working on
the Sistine Chapel or something nobody
else may think it's a great painting but
I get to paint my own painting I do not
have people second guessing me I do not
have been people saying why don't you
use a little more red paint and blue
paint why does your paint a Seascape
instead of a landscape I get to do my
own thing it's it's it's a form of
creativity it's exactly like somebody
feels that the professional golfer or
somebody feels it's a painter they're
not doing it for the money primarily uh
they're doing it because they like doing
something well other they it happens to
good be down the down the uh route of
their talents and the second thing I
like frankly is I like I like applause I
like appreciation so I like having
shareholders who feel good about what
I've done I mean well it's you know I
have a 96 year old aunt uh
and uh her husband on the University of
Nebraska too and she is uh you know she
she has all her money and Berkshire
Hathaway and she counts on me and she's
out in
in Palm Springs now and and her whole
net worth is in Berkshire and I've got
cousins and I've got everybody in our
family has got all their money at
Berkshire and so those people are
counting on me and that's kind of fun to
have something where you can actually
deliver for other people and change
their lives in positive ways as a matter
of fact we had a couple
that nobody had ever heard of up until a
few years ago the ofteners in in New
York they came from Omaha down after
went to Central High at othmer uh uh I'm
not sure which high school she went to
normal probably South High
they left 750 million dollars when they
died nobody ever heard of them and I
think a substantial portion yeah went
right here to the University of Nebraska
it was probably a total surprise to the
university uh when they got I don't know
you probably got 150 million or so yeah
yeah
well you should thank the albumers but
nevertheless you know you see the money
you see good things happening out of it
so it's fun I mean it's uh you know it
beats it beats playing golf every day or
something of the sort so I say if that's
what turns me on what's going to turn on
these managers that are out there
running things like Clayton Homes or or
we've got a company flight safety with
trains more pilots than anybody in the
world fight safety is run by an 85 year
old man Al yulshi Al started the company
with ten thousand dollars in 1951 it now
trains four or five times as many Pilots
as a non-military Pilots as any as
anybody in the world
and he is there at 85 and then it's a
matter of public record he's got a
billion dollars worth of Berkshire
shares he works seven days a week he
loves it and he loves it for the same
reason then I love what I do he gets to
do it his way he buys these big
simulators that she's trained pilots in
he doesn't have to check with me as to
whether to spend 15 million dollars for
a simulator he doesn't ask me he knows
so much more about it than you know than
I do why in the world would he ask me
well I can't tell what kind of a plane
I'm in you know what I'm flying around
and and Al is spending a couple hundred
million dollars a year on simulators uh
suspending Berkshire Hathaway money and
he never checks with them all he's never
had to come to Omaha uh for any kind of
meetings he runs his own business and
that's what he loves in life and I let
him do it I mean that's my contribution
to it is is really turning loose his
energies and you know they were properly
directed before we bought the company
seven or eight years ago by the way why
should I think that you know we couldn't
keep running it after that and like I
said 85 he's still running it
um the second thing that our managers
like in addition to this painting their
own painting is is they too love
Applause I mean I I try to be I I report
in my annual report accurately what
they've accomplished but they
accomplished a lot you heard Susan jock
I think uh some weeks ago here Susan
came to borsheim's and she was making
four dollars an hour four dollars an
hour and at age before she was 40 she
became CEO of the second largest
independent jewelry operation in the
United States you know from the four
bucks an hour but it's Talent you know
and and Susan knows more about I don't
know about jewelry you know uh you could
hand me a phony diamond or real diamond
I couldn't tell the difference but if I
started telling Susan what to order
in the way of jewelry or I started
telling her what kind of terms to
Extended customers or who to hire or
anything like that you know she doesn't
need that in life she really owns four
chives you know we have the stock
certificate we get the profits get
accustomed to uh but it's her baby it's
her baby she decides you know everything
about that place and and so it's her
creation
and that feeling of ownership is really
extraordinary and it's so much better I
mean it's the way I like to work uh and
it's the way you know it's the way uh
Susan jock likes to work it's the way Al
Yoshi likes to work and Susan
like anybody else in this world loves
being appreciated I mean it should be
something wrong with her she didn't and
the truth is nobody appreciates her more
than I do I mean she is a talent and and
we are lucky to have her and we're lucky
to have all of these other managers so
leadership at Berkshire
really consists
of taking a bunch of people
who in a baseball uh analogy would be
400 hitters and just handing him the bat
and just telling him to get up their
plate and take a big swing uh there's
very little to it Beyond it one thing I
do is I send them a letter we don't have
meetings in Omaha some are managers
there aren't any meetings and there are
no there's no catechism or anything else
once every two years I send them a
letter this is it one or not
roughly one of one and a half pages or
so the only the only instruction they
get from is they don't they don't send
budgets to us we don't we don't care
about those some of the companies use
budgets some don't use budgets we adjust
to them some of the managers I talked to
a couple times a week because they like
to talk frequently some of them I talk
to literally once a year because they
don't like to talk to me and whatever
you know it's up to them I I adapt to
them the only thing I tell them and this
letter which went on January 20th 2003
it says it's been two and a half years
since my last memo now I'm a big company
said you have the managers out there
been two and a half years since they've
heard from the home office it's been two
and a half years since my last medal
here are a couple things to keep in mind
and number one and this is number one
every time this doesn't change it won't
change two years from now or four years
from now or six years number one we can
afford to lose money even a lot of money
we cannot afford to lose reputation even
a shredder reputation
let's be sure that everything we do in
business can be be reported on the front
page of a national newspaper in an
article written by an unfriendly but
intelligent reporter
in many areas including Acquisitions
berkshire's results have benefited from
its reputation and we don't want to do
anything that in any way could turn his
ship last year Berkshire was ranked by
Fortune as the fourth most admired
company in the world this year we were
third in the United States they just
published it
it took us 37 years to get there but we
could lose it in 37 minutes
and that's the message I mean we you
know we we can't lose money you know
it's nicer to make money but we've got
we'll figure out ways to make money
but we can't lose we can't lose a
shredder reputation
because you don't get it back and you
can I said 37 minutes because you can
lose it a lot faster than that you can
lose it in five minutes and and and in
fact I was talking to Bruce coming in
and he did some work around Solomon
Brothers and I went back there
11 years ago because this firm
which had was this it had the second
largest balance sheet in the United
States at that time it was it was a
preeminent firm on Wall Street John good
friend who would who ran it
had his picture on the front of business
week as the king of Wall Street
and in April
late in April 1991.
he made a fateful decision it was
reported to him
that an employee down the line had flims
land the U.S treasury of broken some
rules
try to play games with him
and John did not report that fact to the
treasury here to the Federal Reserve
or the SEC or anybody else
uh he didn't do anything wrong himself
but he just he got behind the curve he
didn't report it the president of the
company Tommy Strauss didn't report it
if you saw that
Katie Couric show on Sunday night on the
central part jogger Tom Strauss was on
there but Tom Strauss ended up getting
losing his he was president of Solomon
Brothers John was chairman John good
friend uh they didn't do anything they
they dawdled
and after a few weeks the same guy that
had done committed the terrible acts
earlier on May 15th he did the same
thing again at a treasury auction and
now they were in this terrible pickle
because they had known about this on
about April 28th that this guy was a bad
actor and they hadn't done anything and
now in May 15 he does the same thing
again and now if they go they start
feeling it they go and talk about it you
know the people will say why weren't you
in here before
so they just kept trying to shove it out
of their mind and do other things
and it came within inches
of destroying the firm it destroy their
careers I mean John good friend has
spent 30 years in Wall Street and had a
fire fine reputation the king of Wall
Street
was brought down by one simple Act
of omission all he had to do was pick up
the phone Jerry Corgan was headed to New
York fed he had to pick up the phone and
say Jerry
you won't believe this but this crazy
guy in our Treasury Department uh
felony Moser has just done this thing
and I'm terribly embarrassed and what
can we do to make it right I mean you
know and Jerry Corrigan being Jerry
Corgan would have turned red in the face
and gotten very mad and issued a lot of
language I couldn't repeat here but in
the end he would have said thanks for
calling and telling us about it
immediately you know and we'll slap a
fine on you or do whatever is
appropriate and and the next day The
Firm would have gone on fine but but
John good friend actually you know a
perfectly okay guy
but he just he didn't act when it
counted and Tommy Strauss who was number
two the same way and later on they were
fined and and uh
and certainly kicked out of the
Securities industry and Solomon barely
survived 8 000 employees around the
world
had their future in real Jeopardy
because of that single act uh so just
just apply the newspaper test that's a I
I tell our managers I can have a
thousand page book of Ethics I could
have all kinds of rules and Hunters of
you know but in the end just all you got
to do is think about
you know you really want what you're
doing put on the front page of the paper
tomorrow to be read by your parents by
your by your spouse by your kids by your
neighbors by your co-workers and if
you're embarrassed about it you know
just forget about it at uh you know that
you're all going to do well financially
you know the nice thing about it is you
know you live in America in the year
2003 you don't live in Bangladesh
you don't live in America you know 1790
when it would uh you live in a you live
in a society which has a GDP of over 10
trillion
and you just pick up your crumbs and
you're going to do great you know it's
you've all got the qualities it takes
three qualities essentially to do well
and extremely well actually in this
country it takes intelligence
it takes energy and it takes integrity
now everybody in this room has the
requisite intelligence you wouldn't be
here if you didn't I mean it doesn't
take 180 IQs although I'm sure you all
have those but uh it it it it takes it
takes reasonable intelligence you're
getting a great education you've got the
energy that's why you're you know you've
shown up uh in school
and it takes integrity and I say if you
don't have integrity
you know if we don't want to hire
somebody that's got intelligence and
energy if they don't have integrity we'd
better hire somebody that's dumb and
lazy uh if they don't have integrity
because they probably will never get
around to cheating us or doing something
last thing in the world I want is is
somebody that's lacks and Mosier had
intelligence and energy at Solomon he
was he was head of the government bond
trading thing and he had lots of
intelligence and loss of energy and he
went to jail uh and he and he almost
brought down the firm see and integrity
is absolutely an option you know you may
not be able to throw a football 60 yards
and you know you may not be able to run
100 in in nine eight you know you may
not be able to sneak free pointers but
you can choose
where you stand on the Integrity scale
yeah you can't you weren't born wired
one way or the other that is an absolute
choice to make uh and the heroes I've
had in life other than the people that I
felt stood out of that respect my number
one hero was my dad but I've had other
Heroes Tom Murphy men Graham people like
that and
the reason I admired them was not
because they were the smartest people in
the world although they were probably
smart and it wasn't it wasn't because
they made the most money
that meant nothing it's really because I
felt they were the classiest people that
I ever met in my life I mean I saw them
behave
over a year after year after year
in a way that I could write their story
on front page many newspaper and even in
an unfriendly tone I could not do
anything that would embarrass them and
at least they behaved extraordinarily
well and having the right Heroes
you know is this terribly important you
know you tell me who a 10 year old's
heroes are and I can give you a pretty
good prediction about
about how they're going to turn out you
want to choose Your Heroes very
carefully uh because you're going to
you're going to look like them at some
point and you're lucky if you've got if
you've got the right ones I'll give you
an aside and we'll get on to your
questions but it's something you know
you're not parenting most of you but if
you
when you're a parent you are the natural
hero of your child I mean if I mean you
know there's a great big thing here
there's two of you great big Banks and
there's a little tiny child that
depended on everything you are the
natural hero and
and
anything to get to school subsequently
everything else they're going to be
shaped more by what they see in this
behavior of yours toward them than than
anything that will impact them uh later
in their lives and if uh uh they want
you to be the hero you can destroy that
of course and you know you've seen it
done many many times but but actually if
the if the parents are proper Heroes the
child is about 90 of the way home and uh
you know you're lucky if you've had
parents like that and you can be that to
your children or you can you can be
something else and uh you're shaping
that person that it's nice to earn
accounting when you hit the Nebraska but
but the behavior model that you take on
is is incredibly important let's talk
about what's on your mind now you can
ask ask tough questions more fun for me
and uh they can be about business they
can be personal they can be political
yeah you you pick it out
and
good morning when you were rejected from
uh
Harbor Business School
is obviously somewhat of a failure in
your mind how did you uh how do you
adapt your failures in life and making
more success yeah yeah well that's a
very good question you know how do you
turn failure into a plus
uh and it's true when I was at the
University of Nebraska one day I was
reading the daily Nebraskan
and it said in Room 300 or something at
three o'clock there will be this panel
of three uh uh professors here at the
University and they're going to award
the Nathan gold scholarship I don't know
whether you're still you still have that
around and at the time
uh and said it would give you 500 to go
to The Graduate School of your choice I
don't know whether it's changing them
out but but that that was it so I read
this
and I went there to this room at three
o'clock that day or whatever it was I
walked in the room
and there were the professors
and I was the only student that showed
up I mean it really got to him I mean
they were stuck they you know they kept
waiting and looking at their watching
hoping it would be more candidates but
there no one came in so I won 500 by by
default and
now those are usually my biggest
triumphs when nobody else shows up
and so here I was I had 500 to go toward
any it wasn't it wasn't the limiters any
any graduate school for a master's
degree so I applied to Harvard my dad
wanted me to
and uh
uh I shortly heard from Harvard
and they said go to Chicago and meet
this fellow running the new interviews
applicants from the Midwest
so I got on the train and that's what
you did in those days and I spent on 10
hours on the Burlington
going to Chicago
then I transferred to another little an
urban train to go up to this Country Day
School where this fellow was the
Headmaster and he was the big
interviewer for Harvard
and I got there and after about
10 minutes he he said better think about
something else but uh you know he uh
come back later on I was I was 19 at the
time and uh I looked about 12. you know
and I and I acted about eight uh it was
not a great combination uh but so he he
said forget it so I spent that I took a
little bit of an urban train back to
Chicago and I took the 10-hour train
back to online all the time I think you
know what do I tell my parents you know
it's kind of embarrassing uh but
it was it was the luckiest thing ever
happened to me I
because
if I'd gone to Harvard I would have gone
to a two-year
business school i i instead applied to
Colombia where I can graduate in one
year and get a master's degree
luckily
that by the accident of it and being in
the Nebraska National Guard which did
not get called over the Korean War
I missed going in the Korean War
I
I got to meet Ben Graham and we had an
enormous effect on me subsequently
and I probably got my wife that way
because she was going to Northwestern
and I was able to put on sort of a full
court press because I got out in one
year and otherwise uh she she had met
some other guy I mean I I got her before
the competition showed up and uh so it
worked out wonderfully it couldn't have
worked out better and that's been that's
been my life basically I mean the things
you know you will get some
disappointments you know uh but
the future is what counts
that'd be fun
if I knew every decision I was going to
make was going to be perfect it would
not be as much fun be like playing golf
and knowing you're going to hit a hole
in one on every hole you wouldn't play
golf if every time you got on a tee you
just took a swing and the ball ended up
in the hole you know be fun for a few
days you could get on TV but it the game
would not be any fun so it's failure you
know and I wouldn't even consider
failure but there are mistakes or
whatever you want to call it they're
part of the game and in the end you know
you go on and and we made plenty of
mistakes in business we'll make plenty
more and then you know the
Babe Ruth and you know for a long time
it subsequently got eclipsed by a few
fellows but uh he held the record for
strikeouts you know so the record for
home runs it was the highest paid
baseball player until
the modern era came along yeah so it's
it's part of the game if you take big
swings you know you you may you may
you're going to miss sometimes but
the
uh you know the Harvard thing you'll get
a kick out of this maybe I I they
invited me back to the 25th anniversary
of this class to talk to them uh and I
went back
it was It was kind of embarrassing
because this was the 25th reunion and
and the class was talking about the next
25 years to these alumni that were back
after 25 years and my job was to talk
about the next 20 your financial future
in the next 25 years this was in
whatever it was in the mid 70s and right
before me on the program Masters and
Johnson were talking on the next 25
years of their sexualize so nobody
stayed around for my talk
but that night that night at the uh at
the alumni meeting they uh
the fellow was president of classroom
said you know we're big enough to make
admit when we make mistakes around here
and we turn this guy down throw it back
in the water and uh so now we like to
make him an honorary member of their
class
uh so they did it and they voted in
everybody voted for it and I stood up
and I said I recited the story that I
told you
and I told you and I said at the time I
was
kind of philosophical about this you
know I was young and maybe my grades
weren't that good or something and so I
took the took the rejection kind of well
but I said now that I've met the people
that got into class I'm really sore
[Music]
okay who's next
you can answer it I'll repeat it yeah
after you're dead how do you want to be
remembered and how do you go about it
and how do you go about in your daily
life ensuring that you're going to be
remembering that way yeah well really I
only want the the minister to say one
thing at my funeral
if he gets up there
and they play a few little hymns and
everything uh maybe I'll play there was
no place like Nebraska that'd be great I
just want to stay up there and say
my God he was old
I'll settle for that
true there's the to some extent
Berkshire is my creation so I would like
people do they said the people regard
that well that's what Kaus I mean that's
my painting and and and I hope
that people look at
I've been running out for almost 38
years about just about 38 years exactly
and I mean it's only got another 30 or
40 to go and uh I hope that uh that we
have done some things differently than
other corporations we've operated on a
different model
and I hope two things about it actually
I hope a that
that people realize that that model
works and why it works and so on because
it is it does conflict with certain
management Theory over the years
and secondly
uh the the important thing is that it
that it lasts well beyond me I was down
at Walmart six months ago and talk to
their Management Group and it was I had
a great time
what is really astounding I voted for
Walmart as the most admired company in
the in the country last year that was my
that's where my vote went
it was astounding when Sam Walton built
starting in Bentonville Arkansas with a
pickup truck taking on JCPenney at Kmart
and Sears and all these people with no
money you know no real estate no
preference with vendors no credit card
list anything he just took them on and
of course he just ran ran away from them
but the really impressive thing about
Walmart is that Sam died about 11 years
ago
and that there's been no amount of lost
I mean what he instilled in that company
nobody else could have built it like Sam
but David glass first and Lee Scott now
as the CEO they have kept that company
with its special culture uh
going at Full Steam ever since and that
that's really what I hope you know
happens with Berkshire and I've tried to
think about ways to to make that happen
but the real test will be if 10 or 20
years after I die that the special
culture that I think is part of
Berkshire is not only just as strong as
ever but even stronger we have a
situation in Berkshire
where
in 38 years we got all kinds of CEOs up
there running all kinds of businesses
three or four of them in Omaha
we have never had one CEO ever leave us
period to go someplace else I mean that
I don't think I don't know that there's
any place like that in the country so
it's it's been a and we've never issued
a stock option you know that you know
you're reading the papers that you you
know you gotta have stock options to
attract quality people that sort of
thing I mean we never had we've never
had a share them and and and and
in the end I don't know how many dozens
of managers were talking about but no
one has ever
has ever left for another job and uh
someone been offered way more money
uh Dr G Jane who runs our reinsurance
operation probably could have increased
his income 10 times
tenfold I was already making many
millions but but tenfold but he doesn't
want to leave and that is the culture
that I hope we can maintain and that's
what I'd really like to be uh
if I've done anything to contribute to
that continuing after I die that
wouldn't that would be terrific of
course I I actually plan to keep
managing Berkshire after I die you have
to understand that I have given all the
managers Ouija boards you know I I got
these dark rooms are going to go into
and I'll be there
Mrs B at the rest of Ernie Park work
till 103 at Berkshire and she's she's
sort of our examples and and then she
then she took off from work and she died
the next year so it's very dangerous to
to uh quit as early as that
yeah uh am I supposed to be calling on
these people okay good
on Personal Finance how do I handle them
or how do you determine what where you
make your donations oh well
uh we've got a there's a buffet
Foundation
uh eventually it will have everything I
mean basically everything I've made will
go back to society America has been done
it for me and you know it should that's
where it should go uh
I have I've got about an eight Page
Letter
that the trustees have already seen and
so there's very few trustees I don't
believe in large groups of people making
decisions it gets to be you know sort of
Defense to the lowest common denominator
so there's only what maybe five or six
trustees uh interestingly enough not
just by accident but I picked the people
who I trust in the most in terms of both
their intelligence but also their
quality uh to run it after I know people
I feel the surest of a significant
majority will be women it'll be a women
woman controlled foundation and probably
the largest foundation in the world of
the time uh but with a very small number
of manager uh trustees I have in my
letter I tell them
but I'm not going to give them any
specific instructions as to what to do
with the money uh
I tell them that their judgment above
ground will be better than my judgment
six feet underground so in the end I
want them but I want them to do a couple
of things
I want them to attack really big
important causes I don't want them to
give a million dollars here a million
dollars there and everybody that you
know that asks that they know and that
sort of thing so I don't want them doing
things with an eye dropper I wanted to
swing take very big swings and then I
want them to measure what they're doing
by the importance of what they're doing
as contrasted to the Natural funding
constituency for that now taking a
health field I mean you have the
National Institute of Health spending
billions and billions of dollars you
have all kinds of money going into
medical research it'd be crazy in my
view for the Buffalo Foundation to be
engaged in medical research it's not
that the subjects are isn't important
but there's already a huge funding
constituency it would be crazy for the
money to go to Harvard or something
isn't it it isn't a fine educational
institution but you've got all of these
people that give money to Harvard and
they've got a rich alumni base and all
of that sort of thing so I want the
combination of a terribly important
program and the lack of a natural
funding constituency well where do you
find it you find out with unpopular
causes to quite a degree uh Rockefeller
felt somewhat the same way it's
interesting
he was the first
major patron of any sort
of of black colleges in the United
States now if you think about it black
colleges had no fun English issues here
I mean their alumni didn't have any
money basically if you go back 75 or 100
years so there wasn't any money coming
and people didn't you know they didn't
build great businesses and then and then
leave tens or hundreds of millions of
dollars to the institution and it wasn't
it was self-perpetuating and so
Rockefeller stepped in and he he took a
group of black colleges and funded them
in a very very big way and I I admire
that kind of a decision and honestly
wouldn't it otherwise nothing would
happen and and that's what I hope
Foundation do I was with Bill Gates last
week and I considered his foundation he
and Melinda together to their equal
Partners in it I consider their
Foundation to be the most logical big
foundation in the world they're giving
away about a billion dollars a year
now Bill said to and Melinda said to
themselves
how do we save the most lives per dollar
spent in the world
and they decided that in certain major
medical areas
that what was being done abroad
in many countries was zilch in terms of
these things that were easily
preventable by vaccines or various other
things and they decided they could save
huge numbers of lives per billion
dollars spent but they'd be spending it
you know in places like India and all in
Africa where they would get no credit in
the United States and no buildings with
their name no nothing but that was their
metric and that's that's Bill's
soulmetric I mean he doesn't want to
talk about you can go to him with some
proposition to stick his name on
something you know for 50 million
dollars it doesn't interest him at all
he is it's a totally rational one and he
pours himself into it uh he he has
educated himself on on medicine and
particularly medicine outside the United
States in a way that I've never seen
anybody and I've got a good news about
it this you should write down on May 2nd
on public broadcasting there will be a
program
uh where Bill with Bill Moyers Bill
Moyers was interviewing him and Bill
explains his philanthropic thinking
and it it I I went there it was taped at
Columbia University and vacuum agency in
the audience sitting next to him a
little bit the that is going to be a
great program they took about an hour
and 20 minutes and it's going to get
edited down to 56 or 58 minutes but you
will hear as
the old Harris cogent an argument for
rational philanthropy on that program as
you'll ever hear in your life so I I
it's interesting that program came about
because about two years ago
I asked Bill a question
at a group I get together or something
and came to what you asked him I asked
him to talk about the evolution of his
philanthropic thinking
and there were a group of about 60 of us
there and he talked to us and I mean it
was a fabulous talk and I I just I said
you know you got to get that out in the
public domain somehow assume so this
thing with bone wires does that uh
if I die tonight
all my Berkshire shares which are 99 of
my net worth plus go to my wife
uh she dies first go to mate and then it
all goes to the Buffett Foundation
and
it will then be active on a on a very
big big scale and those are the
guidelines and uh who knows what those
problems will be I mean it probably it
might well have been civil rights in the
early 60s I mean at the Civil Rights
organizations you know we're not being
funded by anybody and I mean it money
wasn't the big problem but it was a
problem for in the Civil Rights Arena
and uh
there was no natural funding
constituency for that it was an
important and very important issue but
it was an unpopular issue in many
respects
and it seems to me that's where the
money money should go particularly they
have it on a big scale where you can
really do something uh depends when I
die but but
you know 10 or 15 years from now the
foundation could really I mean it could
have a lot of money and and uh
so they could do some things that nobody
else could attempt and it won't be what
people want them to do you know that's
the nature of it it's what people wanted
to do it'd already be being done uh the
interesting thing the contrast between
business and philanthropy is interesting
in business I swing at easy pictures I
stand there to play and if I like
pitches one inch above my navel right in
the center of the plate
I can wait and wait and wait because
there's no called strikes you know as
long as that bat's on my shoulder
nobody's calling a strike if the
pitchers froze me General Motors at 36
IBM at 82 Microsoft at 25 and I don't
swing it's not a strike it's not a hit
either but it's not a strike only when I
swing is it a strike so I wait for easy
pictures I wait for things I understand
here exactly in my sweet spot
philanthropy is just the opposite you're
looking at the toughest problems the
world faces and they're intractable to
some extent I mean these are tough tough
problems and they have resisted
you the utilization of money over the
years and that's what makes them tough
problems I mean the problems you can
solve with money are the easy ones if
the problems you can't sell the money so
they are very tough problems one one
thing I've gotten involved in just a
little bit recently is something that
Sam none is heading Senator the former
Senator called the nuclear threat
initiative and uh essentially I say I'm
Not Who was
who was as well informed as anybody in
the world on the subject and articulate
and everything is working on the problem
of the
nuclear materials
and or nuclear talent
that exists around the world that might
become available to terrorists or to to
governments uh to impose on on the rest
of the society and and their their vast
amounts of
of uh uranium and lesser amounts of
plutonium and there's a lot of
unemployed Russian scientists and so on
so this is something that Ted Turner
actually set up a couple of years ago
and got Sam to handle and because AOL
Time Warner stock which was you being
used or funded from Ted has gone down a
lot in price they've run short of money
so that's that's something I'm involved
in and it doesn't uh you know it's not
something that has any popular appeal
you can't raise you can't send out
something you get hundreds of thousands
of people to respond but but uh that's
the kind of thing
that I think you know the foundation
should be doing
and what kind of decision-making process
do you go through when you're looking
yeah the question is will the government
uh considering eliminating the double
taxation on dividends would that change
our attitude at Berkshire toward paying
dividends and what sort of
decision-making uh framework do we have
about whether we paid evidence or not uh
Berkshire I took it over in 1965.
and we paid 10 cents a share one year it
happened in the late 60s I can't
remember it I blocked it out of my mind
I'm assuming the men's room or something
but because uh that was the only
neighborhood we paid uh
the determination is very simple on
devans is
can we retain a dollar
or a billion dollars or whatever the
amount is of earnings
and have that dollar become worth more
than a dollar
in immediate present value now even
though it may not get used for a few
years or something
is that dollar worth more than a dollar
if kept in the business forgetting about
taxes entirely let's assume a total
tax-free Society uh in terms of
dividends
and the answer to that so far has been
yes we have kept the dollars that we've
earned and we have created more than a
dollar of market value for every dollar
we retained and as long as we can do
that it's silly to pay out a dollar even
if it's not taxed and put it in my
pocket or it's still only worth a dollar
if I can create more than a dollar's
worth of value in the stock so we have
done that now for a lot of years it
doesn't mean we can do it forever but
we've done it for a lot of years and
that that is the test and you will find
in the back of the Berkshire Hathaway
annual report which we'll be glad to
send to any of you uh it's on the
internet also but you'll find in the
back of the uh Berkshire report
something that isn't in any other report
that I know of is something called the
economic principles of Berkshire
Hathaway that's been in the report every
year now for at least 20 years and those
principles don't change that's why
they're principles you know and and
that's why I wanted to lay them out I
mean if I act in conflict with those
principles I expect the owners to you
know call me out but I look at the
investors in Berkshire as my partner now
I'm the managing partner they can't
because I own so much stock they can't
do much on me uh so they ought to they
ought to know what the game is when they
if they join us and that doesn't mean
everybody wants to join us but they
ought to know what the rules are just as
if you and I were starting a partnership
but I was going to run it you'd want to
know you know how we were going to
conduct business and what my thoughts
were and what my time Horizon was would
we ever sell would I make distributions
all that kind of thing so
that those principles cover this point
you raise I don't forget what's the
third or fourth one or something like
that but but it's it's explained there
and I want people to understand I want
our owners to understand it I mean I I
look at every owner when I write my
annual letter to shareholders
ungodly amount of time I mean it's
miserable but uh nevertheless it's
important because it is the one time of
year I'm talking to my partners and when
I started out
I actually mentally put
dear Doris and birdian because those are
my sisters and they have all their money
in Berkshire
they're smart
they're but they're not Financial types
I mean they're not spending their time
on that Albert and I essentially want to
be talking to them as bright people who
don't know a lot of financial jargon
necessarily you know but but they're
interested enough that they'll read a
lot because they got all their money in
it so I don't have to worry about
keeping it short or anything like that
if I if I'm talking about their money
I've probably got their interest and
I I take that off at the very end and
then I take off your door supporting I
put the shareholders of Berkshire but I
want to tell them exactly what they're
in I want it to be just as if our roles
were reversed that's always the test if
Doris and Bernie were running the place
and I was living in Carmel California
like birdie is what would I want to hear
from them the managers and one of the
things I want to hear is just exactly
the question that you ask you know what
is the what is your attitude about
Distributing money from the from the
company because
I get to make that decision along with
the board of directors and they don't
and some managements withhold money
that really belongs to their owners
because they like building a kingdom
some of them you know do a lot of fear
or anything like that I think I'm doing
it for a rational reason and I want to
explain that reason but I tell them how
to test me on that too because I think I
should be tested and and it's it's a
it's a very important
uh relationship
that really has deteriorated over the
years in my view between management and
owners I mean you've seen in the last 10
years
a slippage in my view
of the behavior of American CEOs on the
obvious of all kinds of exceptions but
uh it's very interesting because they're
not culture anymore so there's a few and
they've gotten a lot of publicity lately
but nevertheless they have behaved
as most humans do they've sort of picked
up the behavior of those around them
that's why it pays to hang out with
people better than you are I mean you
know if you hang out with people better
than you are you'll become better
yourself
at uh
everybody behaves better that's around
my wife you know I mean even including
me starting from a low base uh but the
she just has that effect on people and
other people pulling it out I mean you
know when I was in the National Guard
and we would go to Camp you know in
about an hour I was reading comic books
you know I am pretty sure everybody's
reading comic books the language you
know you know every every other word
becomes some form of profanity
everything it just is sync well what
happened to American CEOs in in the 90s
is that they they the behavior the
situational ethics
sort of caused behavioral Norms to sink
I say there's a little like
how may West described her career she
said I was so white but I drifted and
American management drifted uh to quite
a degree during that during that period
uh uh I think I think it's very
important
you know what that relationship is
people have given you their money at
Berkshire Hathaway or any other company
and and I'm I'm a I'm a trustee for that
matter of fact and then the question is
they ought to since I control the place
they ought to know the yardsticks so if
you do go to our website
go to the back of the report and there's
something that says economic principles
and we try to discuss everything that's
important and I tell them I'm going to
put them in there every year so that
they're gonna you know they can hold me
accountable
and so forth if you could elaborate a
little bit on the personal qualities and
professional qualities that you look in
in those Executives that you place yeah
and and the question is about the
personal quality we look for in the in
the executives we place at our various
companies the first thing is we don't
usually place them I mean they come with
them uh we don't have anybody to place
so I have the problem occasionally if
somebody dies or uh to replace a a CEO
but most of our CEOs came with the deal
Clayton Homes which were buying comes
with Kevin Clayton right here we will
put no one in there
he will run a place just as before but
in terms of the personal quality when a
seller comes to me with a business
whether it's Clayton or any of the
others Ike Friedman at warsheim's uh Mrs
B at Nebraska Furniture Mart when they
come to me
the first question I have to ask myself
because I'm counting on them to run the
place I have to decide what do they love
the money or do they love the business
now there's nothing wrong with liking am
I I mean they all like money but but
they've got to love the business they're
going to have a passion for it because
if I give them a whole bunch of money
and they love the money and they don't
love the business no matter what they
tell me six months from now they'll be
gone you know I mean they'll just all of
a sudden say why am I getting up at
seven in the morning just so I can send
a lot of money to Omaha you know I mean
it it just
it won't work so they have to love the
business I mean I want people with a
passion for the business I used to say
that I had a one-line employment form
one question employment form the
question was are you a fanatic you know
if you answered yes you got the job
because I want somebody's fanatic about
their business you know I mean you want
people to love teaching if if if you're
in a classroom you know you they don't
have a passion for it it doesn't work
very well so I now if they've got the
passion
and our managers do but but not
everybody wouldn't uh the financial
operators don't we've never bought a
business from an lbo operator a
financial operator because they don't
give a damn I mean all they want to do
is make sure your check clears and and
they're gone and it isn't going to work
if we try to buy from them so we buy
from these people who love their
businesses and and then really my job is
just to make sure that I don't mess it
up and create conditions that cause them
to quit loving it for some reason
because they come in loving and only I
can only I can mess it up and they care
about being treated fairly on
compensation but they don't measure it
against everybody else they don't have a
lawyer they're negotiating one day I
mean I don't have a compensation
Arrangement but any of these managers
that can't be put in one paragraph you
know and then I go to other companies
where they have a lawyer coming in and
there's 80 Pages you know it tells
what's happened John which they get paid
Etc so they end up going to jail you
know I I just I won't deal with somebody
that thinks that way
and you know that's why there's a
self-selection process in terms of of
who comes to it there's this invisible
filter out there
that causes the titans of the world and
the AL Yoshis of the world the eye
creams of the world the Mrs ease of the
world will come to us and I made the
deal with Mrs B in
1983. Mrs B had another offer from
somebody else that was somewhat higher
and she just said I don't care she only
owned 20 of the company that she had
four children age on 20
she told them you know I'm selling a Mr
above it she always call me Mr above it
until when she was 104. uh in fact when
I'd walk in the store she said here
comes my new Young boyfriend which I
didn't I don't get that a lot of places
I can tell you the uh uh but she you
know she she built this thing she came
over here
in 1921 or two she landed in Seattle
with a tag around her neck she couldn't
speak a word of English
said Fort Dodge Iowa
she couldn't she couldn't communicate
she just had the tag the American Red
Cross got her out to Fort Dodge and for
two years she got no place because
nobody's nobody spoke Russian and or
Yiddish actually and and so she moved on
off just to be around some other Russian
Jews who she could at least talk to she
learned the English language when her
oldest daughter Francis would go to
school and come home at night and teach
her the words
and she started out and she started
sending 50 bucks at a time over to
Russia to bring her siblings she had
seven siblings and her mother and father
to get them over here
after 16 years she bought all the family
over she'd say 500 in 16 years you know
peddling used clothing whatever and she
started in the restaurant furniture with
500 and it's now the largest Home
Furnishings complex in the world and it
all came from the 500 in a very you know
special woman and can you imagine
building something like that and selling
it you know to some Financial operator
who's going to resell it I'm trying to
go public with a couple years later and
it you know it meant something of course
you wanted to continue like it has
continued and it's that's those are the
kind of people we want to attract
this is so much me selecting them it's
them selecting Berkshire I mean that's
that's the key and and frankly we've
gotten to that position in this country
where the people that do care about
their businesses besides businesses
there's no second choice Beyond besides
Berkshire we got them you know they they
come to us we had a woman Doris
Christopher come to us last year Doris
Christopher in 1980
had two little girls
lived in Chicago lived in a probably
twenty thousand dollar house and she and
her husband both work
she's looking for something to do
to make a little extra money
she thought about catering and decided
that it would take her away from the
kids too much
so she decided that what she knew best
though was she'd been a homework teacher
she knew cooking
and uh as you knew the kitchen and what
was useful to people so she borrowed
three thousand dollars in our life
insurance policy that's all she had she
went out of the merchandise mart in
Chicago and said what's the least amount
of this utensil or that utensil
manufacturer would sell usually it
doesn't
and she took him home
and then she got the address she had the
idea that she would hold these
parties essentially in people's homes
and so she arranged with a woman in
suburban Chicago to hold the first party
she almost turned back she started
driving there she thought I'd laugh at
me and I locked the stuff over and they
won't buy you know what you do you're
very unsure of yourself but she went
there she sold I think 175 dollars worth
of goods that night
she sold me her business last year
and
uh that business
made 140 million dollars pre-tashed from
this three thousand dollar investment
that woman had a passion for a business
and she understood her customer and she
loved her customer she loved the people
that worked with him she has 67 000
Associates it's called the Pampered Chef
some of you may have been to a Pampered
Chef party and almost one woman out of
10 in the United States bought something
from us last year and uh now
unfortunately I have to acknowledge that
she probably didn't understand
accounting that well but she understood
her customer and she understood people
and and she likes she likes people you
know I I met her one time it's when she
wanted to sell her business there
wouldn't anybody else to sell to as far
as she was concerned she just she came
home all we made a deal in a few minutes
uh we made a compensation deal to just
you know 15 seconds she's running the
business I've never been there they're
in Chicago I hope they're there
we paid a lot of money for this I mean
someday we'll buy a business and
there'll just be some guy out of closet
somebody's saying you know I figure
shall I said more on this month but but
uh I've never been there you know I've
met her and I've seen the results of
what she's done and she is in love with
the company
how do I value the business of Berkshire
acquires well the first thing I have to
decide when somebody calls me is is
valuing this business within my circle
of competence
I don't know how to Value Microsoft I
don't know how to Value Oracle I mean if
you know Larry Ellison calls me or Bill
Gates calls me and they don't but if any
of those I don't know are biotech or
anything I wouldn't know how about you I
just you know I wish him well and tell
them yeah I think it's worth twice as
much as they think it is but I'm just
not in the mood to buy today uh I I
don't know so it has to be within my
circle of confidence my circle of
confidence you know businesses I can
understand and when I say understand I
don't even understand how to use a
computer or not use a computer in terms
of a computer company I mean understand
what the economic characteristics of the
business are and what the company's
really going to look like in five or 10
or 20 years Bill Gates will tell you
that that he'd be you know if you're
investing by Berkshire rather than
Microsoft because it's so much easier to
understand what our businesses are going
to look like whereas he's in a business
where you're going to really have to be
doing things differently over time so I
know that Wrigley's is going to be the
number one shoe income in the country I
know stickers are going to be the number
one candy bar in the country ten years
from now it's been the number one candy
bar for 40 years you don't have to be
very bright to understand that when
people lay out 50 cents for something
that they stick in their mouth that
they're not about to experiment yeah I
mean it's so we
we try a local businesses we can
understand now I I got a call a year and
a half ago from a fellow I never heard
of them in Denver his name was Craig
monzio Craig called me up
and never heard of them and he said I've
got a business it's your kind of
business and I'm going to want I want to
sell it here's the reasons
have to be have to do with health and
although I don't pay much attention to
the reasons uh and he said
it's the leading Company by far
uh in the custom picture frame business
and he said let me tell you why it has
what I call durable competitive
advantage that's what I call durable
competitive energy says let me tell you
why it has it he said there are 18 000
people that frame pictures in the United
States little mom-and-pop operations
every time Lincoln will have a half a
dozen you know almost have a dozen or
and they they frame pictures I go over
to get a picture frame and I hand it to
somebody I say you I follow their
judgment I say you know biggest thing I
want is I want a good looking frame and
I want I want it back soon I want I want
quick delivery well with 18 000 people
in that business and a zillion kinds of
picture frames nobody can carry a big
inventory because they don't do that
much business I mean it's not Walmart or
something of the sort
Craig ponzio graduated from middle
school up in Wisconsin went to work in a
tiny little from the made these things
five or six years later bought the place
when it was doing three million dollars
a year now does 300 million dollars a
year and a totally dominates the wooden
custom
frame business why does it dominate it
it dominates it because it calls on
these 18 000 people has a sales force
calling on them six or eight times a
year and it has 22 plants around the
country that can get the frame that the
custom framer orders 85 percent of the
time if they order by five o'clock today
they'll have it by three o'clock
tomorrow afternoon now think of that
coverage that's what the customer wants
they don't care whether they pay 83 or
88 to get the thing framed they they you
know you've got something you want done
and you want it done fast and that
little custom framer those 18 000 people
they want Happy customers and that means
speed of delivery and certainty and all
that you couldn't build a distribution
system to compete with us I mean you
know if just think of trying to build a
distribution system starting from
scratch that would take that business
away from us it can't be done well Craig
explained that to me in about 15 minutes
I never thought about the custom frame
business but I you know I frame pictures
or have people frame before me I
understood the power of that
that was a Monday
uh I said I think we can make a deal so
he came on Wednesday he came at nine
o'clock and they left at nine o'clock
without a deal I've never seen them
since you know he got the money probably
thereafter he wasn't going to come the
annual meeting last year but his wife
was sick he'll probably come this year
he's a good guy and no one can knock us
off in that business
every time I buy a business I say to
myself if I had a billion dollars and I
want to go and compete with these guys
could I knock them off you know if you
gave me a billion dollars and you told
me to dislodge Snickers as the number
one candy bar in the country I don't
know how to do it if you tell me I got a
billion dollars and I gotta make it or 5
billion and I got to make it so that
Wrigley's experiment you know Doublemint
Juicy Fruit all of those get knocked off
the top selling gum lists I can't do it
now if you give me
you know if you give me a billion
dollars and tell me to knock off all the
ladies apparel shops in Lincoln you know
I'll make mints made of them very fast I
mean I have a very good business myself
and I can destroy them
and the real test is you know can some
idiot with a lot of money destroy the
business you've got if he decides to
compete with you and we we try to buy
businesses where no matter who comes
along
you know they've got this durable
competitive Advantage those are the
three words that count and you can make
that you may be able to make that
decision about companies that I can't
make that decision about they have to be
pretty simple for me but we buy things
that you know we have Fruit of the Loom
underwear you know are people going to
quit wearing underwear wow close
but we we sell 44 of all the men's and
boys underwear uh that goes through
Walmart and all of the mass
merchandising chains we've got the
lowest costs around for the loom is a
name that's been around since 1850 or
60. you know you if you can buy three
pairs of shorts from us or six pairs or
whatever for five and a half bucks and
nobody's going to sell them cheaper
why are you gonna buy anything else yeah
so we'll own that unless we mess it up
somewhere yeah
we've got a very potent advertising uh
slogan there so we cover the ashes of
the masses
sort of gets to it
yeah up there
to examine your successes in your
personal life could you repeat that just
a little louder I think I have most of
it but try me again
okay yeah the question is since why
don't since I say one or two years
doesn't make much difference in business
but longer term does how do I apply that
in my life well
and I could probably give you some
terribly philosophical answer on it but
the truth is I get up every day and just
do what I love doing and and uh you know
I want
people around me to have good
experiences but you know I I the truth
is I don't spend most of my time
thinking about that I mean I've already
I spend most of my time thinking about
what can I do to keep Berkshire going
the way it has going but I will tell you
how to apply that and and
it works reasonably well I think it
Berks sure because
we get this self-selection of people to
join it I mean we have created a working
environment where in 38 years nobody's
left it runs it so I you know I do feel
good about that obviously I feel good
about the results of the investors and
you know the ofteners and those people I
mean actually I think a fellow May write
a book about what's happened with all
the money that all these different
people have made in Berkshire but I'll
tell you the test on that and it's a
terrific question
is because you will when you get to my
age you will not measure how well you've
done by how much money you've got I can
guarantee you that you'll all do fine on
money anyway I mean uh you know think
about it seven hours a day
you know you're in a bad name you've got
exactly the same mattress I've got if
you don't listen to it at the furniture
market you know I mean so so that's why
we were on a parody I can't I can't
outdo you you know in terms of my
sleeping enjoyment you can you can match
it by buying this mattress which will
give you a special price and I just
mentioned my name
we eat at the same places you know we
eat a Dairy Queen particularly if you're
in my position because we own it but but
we eat them dolls in Burger King and and
when I leave here I'll stop by a fast
food place our eating experiences are
the same
we travel the same I mean I had a 10
year old car up until about a year ago
you know it just doesn't make any
difference to me they all work we live
in a place that's warm in the winter and
it's cool in the summer and we watch the
Super Bowl on big screen TV you do what
I do it you know we dress more or less
the same I mean I pay more for my
clothes but they look cheaper when I put
them on so we're really we're on a
parody yeah so so the money isn't going
to be that big a deal everybody in this
country is going to you know that with
the intelligence this group has the
energy you have you're going to do well
so what's the difference
what really counts well I would say that
you will measure health is enormously
important and that's a matter of a fair
amount of luck I mean you know so I
won't I don't I'm not sure changing it
I'm just saying you can't do too much
about that but
you will measure your success in life
by whether by how many and extent
whether it's the people you want
at 70 or whatever the age may be you'll
measured by how many of them really love
you you know in the end I mean you can't
you know you you can't buy love I mean
it doesn't work you buy sex you buy
testimonial vendors you can write your
name on buildings you can do all kinds
of things but the you know the only way
you get the you know love is to be
lovable it's kind of irritating actually
you've got a lot of money it'd be more
fun to just write out a check for a
million dollars it's everybody you know
from now on knows me but it doesn't work
that way and in fact it the only way is
to be is to be lovable and and you know
I've got this friend
who uh who came out of Auschwitz
and had at least one member of the
family die there
and
what is it now it's uh
60 years later
you know she still when she looks at
people it's a polished you when she
looks at people
the questions she asked herself in
determining who she really trusts as
friends the one question in her mind is
would they hide me
now when you get to be 70. if you've got
a lot of people that would hide you
you've had a successful life
I know people who have a tremendous
amount of money no one would hide their
own kids wouldn't hide them I mean they
they really wouldn't I mean their
business associates wouldn't or anybody
else if it really came down to it you
know they they don't have anybody's
respect they've got their attention
maybe with money or something with her
but they nobody loves them and uh my
friend Tom Murphy at Cap City Stevie I
mean dozens of people that hide Murph
you know all kinds of people but but I
had my wife you know
that uh Ben Graham A lot of people my
dad it would have had a number and then
like I say that I can I can tell you
people that uh you know everybody May
pay homage to them and the kids may put
up with them and hope they don't change
their will or something but the truth is
that nobody would hide them and if
you've got a lot of people that would
hide you when you get to be 70. uh you
will have a very successful life
okay right in front
[Music]
for yourself and
um which ones have you accomplished and
which one do you still
um go enacted
yeah just in terms of personal goals or
just goals that you've set for your life
that you've accomplished yeah well I
would
you know the truth is the main goal I've
had has been at Berkshire I mean you
know it might be more admirable to say
than I was feeding the poor or something
someplace in India but it isn't true I
mean it it it's been the focus of my
life most of the time the money will be
I think used for very good purposes
later on I don't use any real amount of
it myself but actually somebody else was
going to do most of that and and I
picked good people to do it uh but
you know I I've got three kids of which
I'm enormously proud and they and they
like each other they get you know they
they do things together they work you
know the the family unit works extremely
well but my wife gets 99.9 of their
credit for that I mean if you didn't
turn out well under her something really
wrong with you uh and uh
it's you know it's uh
it's a life that's a lot of fun
but it's I do what I enjoy doing I you
know it uh I I play lots of bridge on
the internet because I you know I'd like
to do that more than anything else I
used to do way more reading I do a lot
of reading but I I used to just read all
the time now I spend 12 hours a week on
the internet playing bridge and I you
know it's it's great
I I will talk to the Microsoft Summit
here in about a month and I tell this
group there's all these high-powered
internet types and I tell them look at
it you know you guys are all failures
because here I am I've got all kinds of
money
you know I've been pulling on the
internet now for 10 or 12 years I spend
12 or 14 hours a week on it mostly
bridge but I do you know the Google
searches and if I'm writing a talk I
look up all kinds of all kinds of
information on it and I read the New
York Times The Wall Street Journal 10
o'clock the night before and all these
things and you guys are getting exactly
120 bucks a year out of me you know I
mean that is a failure they have not
figured out how to get any money out of
me and and I I gave him a stock last
year and this year I'm gonna go back and
say you've made no progress at all
uh it's 120 bucks last year's 120 bucks
this year and in between I've had 600
hours of enjoyment and learned all kinds
of things uh so I I do enjoy you know
that I enjoy that morning anyway now
when I was young I thought I had a lot
of money I you know I I don't want a
professional sports team and I play golf
all the time maybe have my own private
golf course and all kinds of things
just a meeting to me you know I I
have something
where 365 days a year everything is good
I work around terrific people one was
here today that came when they had drove
me down and and I mean I get to select
the people I work with that's a huge
huge luxury I mean literally just think
of it had to work for a boss you
couldn't stand you know or work around
people because your stomach could Churn
it is what I mean it'd be miserable the
ultimate luxury really is doing
something every day that you love doing
with people that show up doing it with
and and I got that and uh you know by
accident or something I say if you if
you
if you take on a job just to make a lot
of money and it causes your summer
concern you know and you go home at
night and kick the dog and all that sort
of thing you know that that's a little
bit like marrying for money you know
it's it's probably a bad idea under any
circumstances
if you're already rich it's crazy right
I mean if I marry for money I mean my
head examined and what's it going to do
you know and so it it's you know it's it
is and we're lucky in this country I
mean we won what I call the ovarian
Lottery when we were born in this
country you know it was four times or
likely you would have been born just
about as likely you've been born in
Bangladesh you know you're born in the
greatest Society in the world so make
the most of it and have a good time
you can find out
well yeah that's a good question why do
I stay in Omaha well I love it and uh
you know my my grandfather went to
Central High my dad went there my wife
went there my kids went there and now my
grandchildren are there they they all my
grandchildren say they they have the
same teacher that my grandfather had
they uh
but there's continuity there's friends
there there's all kinds of things I mean
there's no disadvantage to being a
normal I mean I like New York when I'm
there I've got a house in California you
know and I I get around some but
I can't imagine anything better I mean I
I uh you know what what doesn't it have
I have a home I've never sold a house in
my life I have a home I'm moved into a
1958 so I've been there what 45 years or
so I'm five minutes from the office I
moved in the office in 1962 I've been in
there 41 years we've just gotten so
we've taken a we take a whole floor 41
years to where we can use the whole
floor kind of discouraging uh but there
there I am five minutes from the off
everything's easy
it all works I know I've known the
doctors all my life I've known everybody
and uh uh I feel connected
uh my aunt taught in the public school
system and I'm alive I named The Scholar
and uh
the prize that I give after her but I
mean it all means something and I've
lived in New York for a couple of years
I've lived in Washington DC for some
years I never felt that kind of
connection at all so there's absolutely
no disadvantage you know the uh you know
I get the same information actually with
the with the internet and you know and
Bloomberg and all that I no one can get
any information or any faster than I can
get it and uh
there's just no downside and I think
it's been a terrific environment for my
kids to grow up in I mean my kids have
grown up in a neighborhood perfectly
normal neighborhood I mean you know no
offenses around it no you know no golden
ghettos or anything of the sort they've
gone to an integrated public
school school was probably at between 20
and 30 black students for 75 years they
have great teachers you know I mean I I
think that you know part of education is
a total life experience and uh I think
it's great that we have a public school
system in Omaha if I lived in Washington
or Los Angeles or New York I'd have to
send my kids to private school I
wouldn't want to do that I do wouldn't
because I wouldn't send them to a vastly
inferior school just to prove some point
so but the nice thing about is I haven't
had to make that choice no more I've got
classy Public Schools the same kind I
went to you know 50 or 60 years ago and
they get more out of that experience in
my view they have a better balanced view
of life going through that experience
than you know if I send them off to some
private school
I was with actually last week
there were six couples
um Bill and Melinda Gates arranged it
and and they had the Headmaster of a
private school in Seattle that the bill
went to and it's a classy school but
you know if you're I gather from the in
terms of the public school system that
you're making a conscious decision to
hurt your kid if you don't send them to
a private school if you can afford one
you know and that's why these people do
it and I don't blame them I mean I do
the same thing but the nice thing about
it is that Omaha I'm sure Lincoln as
well and throughout Nebraska we have
kept a good public school system in fact
I think that's one of the most important
things in America because
one of the things that has made America
what it is think about it
3 million people in America 300 million
people in China and a hundred times as
many people they had the same IQs we had
you know they had the same physical
abilities and all that sort of thing
they had a culture that went far back
they had lots of Natural Resources we
didn't know about it then because we
didn't have oil and they didn't have oil
but we both had oil in the end coal all
these things you know a lot educational
institutions that far surpassed ours at
the time and now we end up you know 230
years later we end up with I don't know
36 or seven percent of the world's GDP
you know from those three million people
something about this system really works
now I think one of the things that works
about it is we come closer to equality
of opportunity than any
major country in the world but one of
the keys to having equal opportunity is
a good Public School System you know if
you have one public school system for
the Richer one for the poor you do not
have equality of opportunity and and I
so it's really one of the top things on
my list and what I got asked about you
know what you can do with money I think
that
anything that creates equality of
opportunity
right from the word go I'm talking about
from when you're five years old and
actually my daughter's working on
something that goes back before that but
but anything the crazy quality of
opportunity is what's going to keep in
America but in America that we have now
it's it's vital and there's nothing more
important than that than having a
first-class public school system and
unfortunately this community is where
they've lost it don't get it back I say
that an outstanding